what's up folks today we are going to be
playing rocket League formerly
rocket-powered super super sonic sonic
rock rock powered acrobatic battle car
battle cars Aaron Samson and I'm Jake
Decker and we're going to be showing you
some car soccer so this game is out it
was out starting yesterday go Oh No so
it's out on playstation 4 and PC it's
1999 and if you are a PlayStation Plus
member you get this little gem for free
it might only be yes this but because of
the way PS Plus works it's this month so
make sure you if you're thinking about
playing rocket League download it this
month yeah so both both you and I have
been playing this quite a bit what are
you initial thoughts on it so far wizard
it's a really fun casual game I've been
talking to the developers they came into
our office and also we talked to them at
e3 I think this is a very oh no don't
score my own team rocket League is I
think it's meant to be like a very
casual game you pick up you play for
like you know 20 minutes to an hour a
day you get your get your goals in you
have your fun there's a lot of rewards
in this game I they try and reward you
almost every single round to give you
something like I already have a ton of
cars I've got my magic contrails here I
think that's one of the reasons why it's
easy to play is because you'd only me
play a game of two and you'll unlock
like a new car you'll unlock a new decal
yeah there's just like a lot of little
little things to it that'll keep you
coming back I guess the devs kind of
throw around that term easy to play hard
to master it's always a little bit of a
gimmicky thing to say but I think in
this case there is a pretty like the
learning curves a little steep at first
when you actually have to figure out
your timing on the ball so learning
learning to actually every day everybody
starts this game like it's peewee soccer
you know with all like the little kids
just chasing the ball and then after you
played for a while you learn to use the
boost better Oh rescue yeah I was also
pretty cool doing is when you boost into
an enemy car and they just explode yeah
if you get a maximum boost
you can actually destroy the enemy car I
scored one goal the other day where I
actually kicked the ball into their goal
and and destroy their goalie on my way
in which is super satisfying there's
also a whole subset of aerial maneuvers
you can do in this game it's tough
though that's it that's sort of a high
level don't hit it out of the goal we're
trying to get to there's a whole set of
Ariel's that you can master in this game
that are actually pretty hard to learn
so that's sort of that's the thing
that's what the developers are talking
about with the sort of the upper end of
skill yeah one cool thing i've noticed
area you can in fact drive on the walls
in this game which is you think it's
kind of pointless but actually you know
if the balls in the air and you drive up
the wall jump off at the right time and
hit the ball you can actually send it
you know towards their goal you can get
some distance on the ball one of the big
mysteries in this game that the
developers wouldn't actually confirm or
deny was whether these were meant to be
RC cars are full-size cars get in there
I will say I do kind of find this game
addicting I was playing it yesterday
just practicing and I kept meaning to
put the game down to go get a coffee and
found myself continually playing rounds
yeah yeah no I was I played a couple
hours yesterday to get ready for this
and I kind of want to play this again
the other cool thing is they have cross
promo with warframe blacklight
retribution like they cut these funny
Sony deals get it in oh um so like right
now I have a warframe flag I have a
bunch of sort of a blacklight flag I
have a bunch of warframe flags to um you
know again the unlock rate is pretty
high in this game so you'll find a lot
of satisfaction oh yeah No ah they I
finally did something useful right the
other thing you AI in this game what do
you think of its own yeah like word I
haven't played against other players yet
because I'm still just sort of learning
the game no no no no dai is ok it your
your friendly team AI does some kind of
silly things like they'll
kick the ball into your own goal at
times or it feels like they just kind of
chase the ball oh there it is there you
go movie it feels like they just chased
the ball but you can also set their
level of intelligence I have been scored
on by my own team several times and the
other one which I actually hate is when
I set the ball in a trajectory to get a
goal and then one of my AI teammates
comes into the last minute and like taps
it and they get the credit instead of me
oh yeah that'll happen a lot like I made
the kick but sometimes it calculates
just whoever the last person was to
touch the ball but you do getting a
little assist award it's not the same
you know yeah it's the work but again
rewards are not something this game is
lacking you unlock this game at a pretty
fast pace there's also a good variety of
tracks there we go there's a game
jejejeje for the win and you got to hit
that team fat antenna you can equip now
that's just equipment now let's get that
on there um right now I'm just playing
in a we get this here are you your 12a
now yes you're pretty good but this is
just against I just said it's like the
second level of AI know so yeah we know
why you're learning it's actually one of
the things that's hard this game is
learning to hit the ball like jumping at
the right time yeah the ball is not an
easy skill to learn it takes it took me
a couple hours yesterday that that's
usually my biggest problem is all speed
towards the ball and I'll miss the
bounce i'll go right under it or
something like that and so rather than
just look at the ball a lot of times
what I'll do now is I'll look at that
little disk on the ground instead yeah
get it do you use the game ball camera a
lot yeah I mostly use the ball camera
you do that by pressing triangle so like
I'll turn it off sometimes if I need to
go for these super boosts oh why they
score don't score oh sit lucky there you
can turn it off sometimes when you're
going for the super boosts kick it out
see I got credit for clearing the ball
seemed progress oh yeah do you do some
donuts you get the celebratory everybody
gets launched out of the gold thing
maybe I'll Drive on the ceiling just to
show people those are the ceiling yeah
if you go fast enough okay i'll see if i
can just flat-out make a goal start off
with go go go girl yeah better it's too
high know what I've noticed is if you're
too far away and you try to get that
little blue skull you'll knock it too
hot if you boost the entire time so the
keys to start your boost a little bit
later but on the higher difficulties i
found out of that doesn't work at all
everyone cuz everybody gets their fair
one yeah everyone just not only that but
if the ball gets knocked at above you
and two people collide they'll explode
yeah okay gotta get stop it and see if
you can demolish one of these cars oh
yeah should be 2 r.d let me grab a super
boost so then right now if those little
yellow fields that's how can increase
your boots than that number down the
corners how much boost you have right
now we're it sitting pretty at zero
except for these guys here yeah those
guys max it out max it out and then you
can let me see if I can get in there and
kill somebody nope no right to right oh
here we go alright let's take our heater
it's actually a lot of this game is
about anticipating where the ball is
gonna go next yeah that's what I found
myself doing a lot of rather than trying
to just go for the ball right no let my
teammates you know battle football and
I'm kind of weight in the back a little
bit and see where it's gonna go you may
or may not be able to hear it but I've
got some majestic magic coming out of
the back of my car every time I boost
alright heater we're gonna put the ball
get it oh yeah you get pretty good at
and the easier difficulties of like
getting the ball in on the kickoff
that's always a possibility it's good
for one of your cars be if you're
playing with other people too it's good
for one of your cars to hang back as a
goalie yeah cuz a good hit from across
the field no see he just seemed
as my teammate totally scored on my team
okay here yeah let's even get the good
angled shot get in get it all knocked it
a little bit too much too right hey go
nope so you haven't had a chance to play
online at all with this right now i
don't i'm assuming that other players
are pretty good at this game from
playing the previous versions yeah I I
mean there's got to be a lot of people
who never heard of this though right but
I tried playing a little bit and I
couldn't connect to the service I don't
know if that was yesterday yes n was
down how it might have been I don't know
what Lester Romanians you know it's
funny actually one of the guys who
worked on this game worked on socom I
was like how do you go from so so come
to supersonic at all the cars guns no
guns well guns lots of cars and
explosives whatever get this it'd do it
dear do it hey god see that's back to oh
wait oh no its back to like timing that
bounce right there yet timing the jumps
is huge in this game that's that's a
massive part of this game and then I
think the other half of it is just
anticipating where the ball is gonna be
next juggle it get it in there you go oh
um yeah you know again getting getting
out of the peewee soccer mentality where
you're actually anticipating the ball
rather than yeah definitely I don't know
don't score my own team again oh you did
it again whose team are you on Hollywood
we gotta kick out Hollywood we got to
cut them whose team are you on alright
we're only down one let's do this ah
near miss playing and talking not easy
yeah this game requires a lot of
concentration a surprising amount of
concentration oh there's a good chance
to just get a full field goal I like how
they have these cars have hats
so it's a nice little toe you live up
now you got one yeah detonated I mean as
you can see we've got the Oh where's it
gonna get it hey yeah 22 mm-hmm bounced
off the ceiling I mean this is gonna go
into overtime I'm gonna do this I'm just
gonna get school just gonna bring it
home right now bring it home you know
it's funny so some of the cars are
easier than others I feel like the cars
with the rounded edges it's a little bit
harder to predict where the ball is
going to go there's a just a van
actually I think heater is the van yeah
there's just a van that's like um I'll
just some key straight it's a blocky
shape and it makes it a lot easier for
your eye to figure out where the ball is
going to land are the other boosts the
others that's between these cars no oh I
was close you know the other thing I
like about this game is I used to play
street hockey and it has that feeling of
you can play the ball you can play the
man right yeah so if somebody's about to
score a goal you don't have to go over
the ball you can just get the guy just
take the guy out or comes back to
demolishing them right if you boost in
doing more if you just knock them away
they are just knock them away so that
they can't make the shot it's kind of
like how in street hockey you can just
grab the stick have somebody who's about
to score rather than rather than worry
about you like [ __ ] yeah all right let's
bring this home bring this gamespot
place home get it in no come on it's
gonna be our last one gotta win this one
so are there are there like stat
differences between the cars are just
kind of size cuz that's one thing I
couldn't figure out when I was playing
it seemed like it largely just came down
to cosmetics yeah they all felt like
they handled relatively the same no you
don't ok you can also like jump and do
tricks in the air even though oh there
you go got'em yeah like running up the
side wall of the field and then learning
how to where the ball is gonna go is a
big thing and also like using the side
wall to bleed momentum is it is really
useful oh no oh here no no yeah
oh yeah teammates going twice heaters
heater in Hollywood are just screwing us
man what are you doing heater what was
that who you scored on all right I got
to get one more goal before he can i
rephrase yeah I mean I refused to end
this on a loss maybe maybe switch up
your team a little bit maybe get rid of
fight you know this would be a good
chance for me to just back out real
quick and just show the garage yeah show
some of the customization options and
then I would get one goal before we end
this I swear all right okay so let's get
out so here's your garage right so
there's this is I've only played a
couple of hours and I already have a lot
of cars um I kind of like that are I
like that it's not you know you're not
gonna debt it you're not gonna have to
dedicate hours and hours and hours in
order to unlock everything instead you
can kind of play casually and you'll
still get a good option of all the
different let's go paladin so then you
got decals you got paint you got wheels
just go over here nice you got fire
trails I got the sacred but you can
change it yeah these can go with a fez
hats go to Fez hat and then right now
I've got all kinds of flags they got at
which flag got to get that promo in
warframe let's go warframe alright so
we're gonna hop back in real quick and
we're gonna get a goal that's gonna
happen I'll just don't make my own match
silly look there's a lot of different
fields different times a day which are
pretty cool let's go Mansfield stormy
there's weather conditions yeah 3 be 3
33 is the standard so those boys a
little bit crazy rookie Pro all-star
unfair yeah and if you notice too unfair
is 1 verse 3 yeah all right this is
gonna be it we're gonna we're gonna
bring this home you know you're gonna
score right off the back here I'm gonna
score right off the bat we're gonna do
rocket-powered super card flipping
battle league acrobat here we go that's
in yeah all right I think that's as good
as spot as any band this all right cool
well thanks everybody for watching that
was rocket League out now on PSN and
steam it's free for PS Plus this month
otherwise it is nineteen dollars be sure
to picked that up now I'm gonna be
playing out the corner of my eye because
I don't want the other team to score
even donuts how we roll alright see you
guys later thanks for watching see ya
you